i
[Música]
descontento en eeuu cientos de personas
se manifestaron en varias ciudades del
país en rechazo al veredicto que
absolvió de todo crimen a call with en
house el joven que disparó y acabó con
la vida de dos personas durante las
manifestaciones del movimiento black
lights matter en 2020 en la ciudad de
que nos
venezuela se prepara para unos comicios
regionales en los que la oposición
vuelve a participar después de años de
llamados a abstención uno de sus
principales retos será recuperar la
confianza en el voto en medio de la
fragmentación que enfrentan los sectores
contrarios al gobierno
y siguen las dudas sobre el paradero de
la tenista china peng shuai periodistas
afiliados a medios estatales publicaron
supuestas fotografías recientes de la
mujer que desapareció después de
denunciar que fue abusada sexualmente
por un ex alto funcionario
agregaron que ha permanecido recluida en
su casa y que pronto reaparecerá en
público
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz
empezamos en eeuu donde hay división y
descontento tras la decisión de absorber
acá el ritz en house quien disparó a
muerte contra dos personas durante las
manifestaciones contra el racismo el año
pasado en la ciudad de que no se ha
estado de wisconsin a las afueras de la
corte y en ciudades como nueva york
cientos de personas expresaron su
rechazo al veredicto que determinó que
el joven de 18 años no era culpable de
los cinco cargos entre los que figuraban
homicidio e intento de homicidio
familiares de las víctimas dijeron que
no estaban sorprendidos con la decisión
de un jurado mayoritariamente blanco y
señalaron al sistema judicial como un
fracaso aunque el presidente joe biden
se declaró enojado y preocupado dijo que
respetaba la decisión de la corte e
instó a la población a mantener la calma
ya
sean de donde sean
solo quiero que la ciudad de que nos
llegue el departamento de policía
entienda que nadie aquí se detendrá
jamás
nadie dejará de intentar exponer las
fallas en el sistema no me sorprende lo
que pasó ahí pero mi corazón está roto
bryant
pasamos a venezuela que vive este sábado
su jornada de reflexión de cara a los
comicios regionales y locales previstos
para el domingo para la oposición ahora
el principal reto es recuperar la
confianza en el voto luego de años de
llamados a la abstención las elecciones
del 21 de noviembre contarán por primera
vez en 15 años con observación
internacional de la unión europea
venía por acá para invitarte a votar
habla con tu familia josé cardoso no es
político ni activista es un ciudadano
jubilado residente de esta parroquia del
oeste de la capital que hace lo posible
para convencer a sus vecinos de ir a
votar por la oposición
hay una mesa de diálogo de entendimiento
entre la oposición y el gobierno que se
respete la condición electoral y estoy
creyendo en ese diálogo tras dos años en
el exilio el dirigente opositor tomás
guanipa aspira a ganar una alcaldía en
caracas convenciendo puerta a puerta a
los votantes de que el momento de
recuperar espacios políticos es ahora no
estamos en unas elecciones libres aún
tenemos que luchar mucho más por
condiciones libres para que podamos
elegir un nuevo gobierno
de lejos luisa observa a los políticos
pasar anhelo un cambio en 22 años
gobernados por el chavismo nunca le han
atendido sus necesidades la batalla de
tanta miseria intentado tanta burla el
reto que enfrenta la oposición en las
próximas elecciones regionales será
revertir la idea de abstención que
durante los últimos tres comicios
infundió en sus seguidores entre otras
razones por desconfianza en el consejo
nacional electoral el analista luis
vicente león explica que no fue la mejor
estrategia si tú no cambias
condenado a que surgiera otro grupo
opositor y otro liderazgo de sourcing
que se tomara completo la lucha por el
cambio en venezuela cambiar el discurso
no será suficiente hay quienes como
maría angélica los venció la decepción
de una oposición que no ha logrado
ponerse de acuerdo una estrategia para
cambiar de gobierno no pienso votar
porque estoy muy desilusionada de la
oposición después de una larga jornada
josé regresa a su rutina convencido de
que el voto es la vía especialmente por
tratarse de unos comicios que por
primera vez en 15 años contarán con la
presencia de la misión de observación
internacional de la unión europea
y crece en europa una ola de descontento
debido a las nuevas restricciones que
varios países han vuelto a imponer ante
el aumento de los contagios por kobe 19
para este sábado se esperan
movilizaciones en austria país que
decretó un nuevo confinamiento y la
vacunación obligatoria
entretanto hubo fuertes disturbios en
países bajos principalmente la ciudad
portuaria de rotterdam que terminaron
con al menos 7 heridos y unos 20
arrestados el alcalde de la ciudad
condenó lo que calificó como una [__]
de violencia
las protestas también se vivieron en
australia donde grupos tanto a favor
como en contra de los mandatos de
vacunación se hicieron sentir en las
calles de varias ciudades las
principales movilizaciones se
registraron en melbourne y llegaron a
otras urbes como sydney brisbane quienes
se oponen a las restricciones exigieron
libertad y el fin de lo que califican
como segregación aunque la vacunación a
nivel nacional es voluntaria algunos
estados han requerido inoculación
obligatoria para muchas profesiones y
han impedido que los no vacunados
accedan a actividades de ocio como
conciertos o restaurantes se estima que
un 85% de la población mayor de 16 años
cuenta con el esquema completo
y estamos aquí hoy por la unidad unidad
en nuestra comunidad la gente vacunada
no vacunada a la policía para reunir a
todos últimamente hay una desunión en
nuestra sociedad son animal
cuando tenemos gobiernos que adoptan
pasaportes de vacunas ya no somos libres
el ex presidente de georgia mikheil
saakashvili detenido por las autoridades
de su país desde el pasado primero de
octubre acordó el viernes poner fin a
una huelga de hambre de 50 días en
prisión las autoridades ofrecieron
trasladarlo a un hospital militar bajo
la presión de cientos de manifestantes
que piden su liberación informe de andré
amaya
las autoridades georgianas trasladaron
al ex presidente mikheil saakashvili a
un hospital militar luego de que un
panel médico asegurara que sufre de
problemas renales y neurológicos el
opositor pasó 50 días en una huelga de
hambre bajo custodia saakashvili dejó de
alimentarse desde el primero de octubre
cuando fue detenido tras su regreso a
georgia después de varios años en el
exilio desde temprano miles de
simpatizantes del exmandatario
manifestaron en las calles de la capital
pidiendo su liberación
lamentablemente georgia está bajo
régimen me refiero a la oligarquía a la
cleptocracia
desafortunadamente aquí no hay
democracia por eso el gobierno actuó de
manera tan irresponsable con respecto a
su vida
somos firmes a nuestro anuncio de que no
vamos a tener mítines cerca del hospital
donde se entregara saakashvili
pero lucharemos por su libertad y
lucharemos por unas elecciones
parlamentarias justas y proporcionales
en un comunicado el ex mandatario dijo
que volvería a comer después del
traslado al hospital pero que nunca
aceptaría su detención ilegal
mikhaíl saakashvili de 53 años fue
presidente de la ex república soviética
de 2004 a 2013 en 2013 ese exilio en
ucrania y luego fue declarado culpable
por abuso de poder y condenado a 6 años
de prisión pero el opositor rechaza los
cargos por motivos políticos el
encarcelamiento del reformista pre
occidental ha agravado aún más la crisis
política en el país que comenzó con las
elecciones legislativas de 2020 cuando
triunfó el partido oficialista sin
embargo el resultado fue considerado
como fraudulento por la oposición el
finalizamos en china- los medios de ese
país dieron pistas sobre el paradero de
la tenista page white cuya desaparición
mantiene en vilo al mundo del deporte el
editor en jefe del diario 'global times'
aseguró que la ex número uno en dobles
está en su casa y que pronto hará una
aparición pública
ha sido vista desde que acusó a un alto
ex funcionario chino de haber abusado
sexualmente de ella tanto naciones
unidas como las estrellas del tenis han
exigido que se revele cuál es la
situación real de la atleta escuchemos
al número uno del mundo novak djokovic
me alegra que se generara una reacción
por parte de los líderes de la atp y la
w tea y es algo muy importante porque
esto es horrible
because veces por find am en dos
versiones me quiero decir una persona
está desaparecida no sé si lo que dije
antes sí sea cierto o no que la
encontraron y realmente espero que así
sea ella era la número uno del mundo en
dobles hasta hace poco y una de las
jugadoras chinas más famosas y china es
un país enorme génesis the hills country
de ser importante
es una parte del mundo muy importante
especialmente para el circuito femenino
tienen muchos torneos ahí es necesario
que nosotros tomemos todas las acciones
y acabo de escuchar que la w está
dispuesta a retirar sus torneos de china
a no ser que se resuelva este asunto y
es algo que apoyó en un 100%
por tanto hasta que esté informativo
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]